okay so today I'm going to talk about
joint work with I do you live not
Christos and avi are Rubenstein and Greg
valiant
and so what we thought about is the
question of how a trait becomes fixed in
a population beneficial trade
and so this question can have many kinds
of answers and sort of the first one
that population genetics gives I think
is you know that they're the trait is
completely determined by a single gene
by selection the gene gets fixed and
then the trait also gets fixed this is
at least sort of the first naive
explanation and but we know that many
traits depend on multiple genes and
population genetics also tries to
account for this so one way that's
normally done is to assume a kind of
independent contribution to fitness from
each gene so it might be additive or it
might be multiplicative or if there are
dependencies there is a simple structure
or some kind of special structure
assumed about the dependencies between
the genes
and one thing that les pointed out on
Monday was that sort of the as we know
more our our standards for explanation
get higher and I think what we know what
we know now and what biology seems to
tell us is that you know a trait is can
be the product especially many of the
traits that we care about can be the
product of a very complex interaction
between very many genes and so what we'd
like is is is an explanation that that
can use what we know about population
genetics without making any assumptions
about what we don't know from biology
which is how you know sometimes multiple
genes will come together and produce a
trait and we'd also like a
polynomial-time explanation
because the trait may involve many genes
so how do we think about this problem
well we consider n genes which I'll call
x1 x2 through xn and they'll interact in
some way which we may not understand but
but at the end of the interaction that
either a trait is is produced or it's
not so here we'll we'll think of genes
as having two alleles each and so we'll
will write the setting to be either plus
1 or minus 1 depending on the allele so
what we might know is that for different
settings of these genes a trait will
either be produced or not and we don't
understand necessarily how the trait is
produced and what we want to know the
question we want to know is that if the
trait is present in the population what
happens over time will the trait become
fixed in the population how long will it
take and and what will the genotypes of
the population look like after a
fixation
so let me describe a concrete example to
explain how we thought about this
problem in 1953 Waddington conducted
experiment and experiment on a
population of flies and the first thing
that he did was he applied heat shock to
the young flies and then he found that
some developed a special structure in
their wings which he which is called
cross stainless so the wing of the fly
will have veins running this way and
normally in the in the population you
also have veins going here and when he
found after applying the heat shock was
that you know in some of the Flies these
these veins weren't present after
development okay so so then he selected
just those flies that that satisfied
this property and then he reproduced
them to create the next generation
and and then he repeated this for many
more generations and so what did he what
did he see and you know the first time
he applied the heat shock maybe
something like 23 percent of the Flies
developed this cross painless wings you
know in the second generation the
percentage went up to something like 56
percent and you know within roughly 25
generations
nearly all nearly all would develop
across being the swings after applying
the heat shock okay and I guess this is
not this doesn't seem so surprising you
know this is how we get Bulldogs from
Wolf's forever so but what was
surprising was for some of the flies he
didn't apply the heat shock and some of
these flies also developed across famous
wings so whereas before the heat shock
was necessary to bring out this feature
it happened without
so one thing that's interesting about
this example I think is there is no
single gene explanation for what happens
with the numbers that Waddington got and
two years later Stern gave an informal
explanation that uses threshold
functions and I'll try to give you the
sort of generalization of this
explanation
okay so suppose that whether or not you
have cross vaneless wings is a function
of these and genes and also whether or
not you apply the heat shock then you
could so I'll say that this is roughly
an over three so that you know yours one
setting to the genotype will determine
and also whether or not there's heat
determines whether or not the features
present does this make sense so far yeah
at the beginning so if we so now what
how do we keep track of the genetics of
the population so we start with you
start with what the genotype frequencies
of the population and to compute the
next generation so this is a time T at
time T plus one
so here G is just the function that's
one exactly when this condition is
satisfied oh sorry
it'll be one when the condition is
satisfied and zero otherwise
yeah okay sorry I would like to take the
excise to be plus one minus one yeah
it's just I think eventually makes the
explanation clear but it's not too
important we would just switch around
the value and so you know what this is
just the average value of the excise in
the next generation if we have random
mating and full recombination and we
take these marginal expectations and for
the next for the distribution of the
next generation we we use a product
distribution where each of the
expectations of the bits is given by
this average
and so after doing you know the
calculations you find that
after enough time the the function is
almost always satisfied when you so this
is the variable for heat shock right and
you also find that the the new eyes have
gone up and what this means is that the
function will also be satisfied when no
heat shock is applied
you I is the fraction of flies that disk
image generation with gene hi
sorry so UI is the the average value of
gene X I over the Flies that had the
cost of aimless swing feature yeah
thanks I think since so all we've done
is we've you know accounted for
selection and we've assumed that we're
in a product distribution that were on
this right manifold
this one what sorry sorry it's a corner
oh this one yes and it's also maybe not
really a quarter okay so yeah I started
measuring this you know this is an
approximate calculation we've one thing
we're assuming is an infinite population
right we're just keeping track of the
distributions and not accounting for
sampling effects and we also assume that
we can describe each generation by a
product distribution but I'll talk more
about those assumptions when I sort of
pose the general question this is like a
generalization of it I mean you know
flies are so I've assumed also that you
know the Flies are haploid when they're
actually diploid and you know Stern's
explanation involves actual actual genes
and the Flies and he's trying to get the
same numbers but this is sort of the
idea
I think it was like eight this is yeah I
could yeah okay okay so in some sense
this should happen regardless of the
starting distribution right because
because partly because of the infinite
population and yeah I mean it's only
really a good approximation when the
Flies are somewhat when the condition
will hold with some good probability but
it's also you know if you just look at
the infinite case it will still happen
no matter what
yeah that's true yeah okay okay but so
this is a specific solution to you know
this particular trait and I you know
promise that we want to you know not
assume anything about how the genes
interact or assume that the function
looks like a special function okay so
what we want to consider is arbitrary
boolean function
Oh
and so now we're going to consider
arbitrary boolean functions and we'll
call them F instead and instead of being
zero one value will let us take two
values just 1 plus Epsilon or 1 so this
is because we want to consider week's
election so the Washington's experiment
is a very harsh sort of type of
selection and you know we're interested
in less aggressive kinds of selection
and so sometimes going to talk about
satisfying F and that just means you
know that it takes value 1 plus Epsilon
and you know what F is is going to be
the additional fitness that you get by
having the trait right and otherwise f
of X is minus sp1
okay and so we still will be keeping
track of a product distribution at each
generation for the average values of
each bit is
so now we're just waiting according to
this week's election instead of of tea
but this is still what the average value
would be with random mating and full
recombination starting from if your
parents come from this distribution then
this will be the average value of the
next generation and then we're going to
assume that the next generation is
actually produced by the product
distribution that these average values
describe just so-so I mentioned you know
so there's the fact that we're assuming
their product distributions and who mesh
a couple days ago covered this issue
similar issue in his talks so will
appeal to now you're lucky theorem
so we know in the absence of selection
after roughly login generations we do we
do move to a product distribution over
the marginals and Naga Lucky's theorem
says that with weak selection after
enough generations
the process we consider over the right
manifold will be a good approximation to
the actual process okay so
so the first thing we can show is that
which is more general than the last
thing is that if F is the monotone
function so a function is monotone a
boolean function is monotone it when
it's satisfied at a point flipping a bit
from a minus 1 to a 1 means the function
has to be satisfied at that point as
well and if the starting probability so
I'll use this for the starting
probability then in linear time there
are this many generations the
probability that I'm satisfied is is
very close to 1 it's so so what about
general general boolean functions which
is the goal we set out with so if you
think about it we'll see that with the
way we've defined this framework we
can't we can't dip this so the xor
function yeah the starting function
which we understand that seems tough for
biology
so for example if you start on the
uniform distribution they were all these
expectations the average values are zero
I the plot the function will be
satisfied with probably half but you
know in the next generation you won't go
anywhere you'll just stay in the same
place it is unstable and so that brings
us sort of to the next single think
about so like I said the this is an
approximation in one of the ways it's
it's an approximation ISM that we're
assuming an infinite population and we
know that sampling effects are an
important sort of part of what happens
to populations and you know there's
fixation without selection in this case
it turns out that sort of random drift
is is going to be important for fixation
of this beneficial trigger so what we
can show with finite populations is for
any boolean function
so we'll take a fixed population size
and now both the polynomial and F 1 over
epsilon and whatever the starting
probability with almost you know with
probability almost really almost 1 the
population all has the trait every
individual the population will have the
were so yeah this this statement I'll
I'll define all the generations but
we're assuming that you know at this
beginning this is when you've started
from a product distribution and you're
always in a product distribution I mean
that's what the theorem is proved for
oh yeah it's a population side sign if
you're by the population size yeah so I
think you know what we're saying is that
you're close to it so you know if you're
in a given sample you're not but when we
produce the next generation we'll assume
you're coming from that product
distribution that's given by the
frequencies of the yeah yeah so let me
yeah let me say a little bit more about
the finite population so we assume you
know if you have a population at time T
can everyone see you down here that
wants to okay
you know well first we'll start with a
product distribution in time T will take
a finite sample of size n and this will
give us a new distribution and then yeah
so there are some restrictions to the
parameters before yeah oh sorry okay so
any yeah it's a boolean still so you
know what we've assumed about the
interactions is that between the jeans
is that you know there are two alleles
for each gene and you know however
they're set we don't really understand
whether or not the trait gets produced
but it's determined by that and so I
guess the boss wants to describe with
beauty measure of the points that F is
equal to one plus Epsilon oh so sorry my
so by this I mean a probability so this
probability is one so that by the end of
this process every every everything
satisfies everything individual well the
expectation of F will be the expectation
of F will be 1 plus Epsilon
sorry it's just Batman yeah I'm using
this for the density yeah there's only
two values I mean so you know we've in
order to raise your standards
sometimes you first have to lower them
so we you know we're simplifying in
other dimensions but sort of the
complexity of these interactions at
least you know to a computer scientist
seems you know yeah
and so you know there are we do have
some restrictions I mean this election
right now it needs to be less than one
over n the strength this election
although we believe that even for
constant epsilon this should be true and
the starting probability depends on the
population size to some extent so it has
to be substantially more than say one
over the population size you know we're
so there's no yeah so for learning
parodies the idea is that you know the
function could be labeled by an
arbitrary parody you don't know which
one it is and what's difficult is to
determine what it is when you see sort
of inputs and outputs to the function
that's what's difficult about learning
varies so here you know we have yeah
this could be the case if F were the
parody function then you know at the end
of this process in fact so if I go a
little bit further you'll see at the end
of this process all the genes will be
fixed and they'll be fixed in a way that
satisfies the function wise yeah am I
out of time okay so yeah so we won't see
that but that's true
yeah otherwise you won't always be
satisfied because you'll have the
product distribution and those yeah okay
so I guess if there